what up guys welcome to the chest pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and like the video as
that is the most important metric that
YouTube uses to push out these streams
also guys make sure you sign up for our
email list that is in the description I
could be kicked off these platforms any
day and if that happens I want to make
sure that I can connect with you guys
also guys get yourself a women shouldn't
vote t-shirt today shipping has begun
this week so if you want a women
shouldn't vote t-shirt make sure you get
one below they're very soft comfortable
and will turn you into the ultimate
alpha male okay guys so today I wanted
to react to a clip of this woman
speaking about being a 39-year-old
virgin so let's pull it up are you still
a virgin I am oh my God I love this this
is the most original guest we've ever
had on and you what are you 39 I am oh
my God that dam is going to break one
day baby and let me play right now I
like people were like oh you know Ian I
was like pray for him whoever he
is a lot of pet up energy up in here oh
my God and you're going to hit your
sexual peak when you start having sex so
yeah you're going to need a couple of
men
probably you all went from being a
virgin to
poy okay I wanted to point out a couple
things from this clip one how old [__]
will always try to drag the more pure
women into promiscuity they will always
do this misery loves company and when
someone is miserable they will try to
drag you into it second thing I wanted
to tell you guys why being a virgin over
a certain age is a red flag to men now
don't shoot the messenger I am just I've
interviewed thousands of people on the
these type of topics and over a certain
age Men start to wonder why you're still
a virgin so why at 39 it would be a red
flag they will assume one that you are
lying two that you are crazy because in
their heads it's like well why is this
woman like why did no other guy want to
deal with this women um or three you
will never be happy and no guy is ever
good enough um or you're extremely
unattractive which she actually she
wasn't an unattractive woman so it's not
that but over a certain age guys just
assume you're lying or something is
batshit crazy about you or you're
basically asexual what age that is it
kind of varies I would
say after 25 to 35 somewhere in there it
becomes a red flag let's pull up the
comments to this
video I don't know why people think she
is lying because this is how men think
okay and this is the thing women are so
immune to how men think that they just
expect men to believe a chick that hits
40 years old she's had almost half of a
century to have sex and they just want
them to believe that she has never done
it and it's also because many women do
lie about this stuff guys I have had so
many women come on the show and say that
they're virgins I I've even had a girl
come on the show say she was a virgin
and have a different guy call her out
for sleeping with somebody on the show
like this is the stuff women do so you
know she could be telling the truth but
you have to understand this is how guys
think about it she has been speaking
about this for years now she's saving
herself heartbreaks unwanted pregnancies
and STDs and I wanted to also point out
that this is fear-based thinking um and
you know everything in life comes with
risk and I think it's actually a good
thing when women wait till they're
married I'm not saying that's not a good
thing but sometimes you find women that
are so afraid to get into a relationship
that they just avoid them all together
and the problem is you don't get
anything good in life when you go into
things with a fear-based mentality
things can always go wrong always always
always um salute to her for not
conforming to this BS sneaky link hookup
culture so I actually agree with the
last thing I do think that is a good
thing but you know my question is at
what cost you know like what is the
problem because I'm sure there have been
she's not an unattractive woman I'm sure
there have been a plethora of men that
have tried so it's either that she's
lying she wants men out of her League or
she's crazy this is how men think about
it so the next comment
says ain't no point of doing it now you
went 40 years without it you can do 40
more okay the next comment um and you
see that you see that how like women and
you you can notice this she's got the
big hoop earrings typically a ton of
makeup they start to shame women for
being more more pure women that are more
pure are automatically shamed by other
women and this is why you see women that
really lead each other into destruction
39 and a virgin with the last name orgy
still
crazy um so at 39 most men will kind of
assume you're lying or that you're
literally bat [__] crazy and you know
what else is crazy geopolitical tensions
are escalating inflation is raging and
despite what they say stocks are sinking
debt is rising and your own financial
future isn't looking too clever yet gold
endorses every crisis Wars disasters no
Calamity has beaten gold while paper
assets crash and burn gold endures every
single time and you need to take a fresh
look at gold studying your portfolio and
right now you get a free 5 ounce America
the Beautiful coin when you open up an
IRA with Noble gold Investments to today
Shield your savings with Noble gold
Investments go to noblegold
investments.com noblegold
investments.com the only gold company
that I trust So speaking of crazy um you
guys know I've been covering the story
of Joe Smith a former NBA Legend and his
wife facing difficulties in their
marriage due to his wife starting and
only fans funny thing is when I covered
this video last time the woman basically
saying that money was worth the only
fans and he didn't notice for a year do
you know what the comments were in the
video oh he didn't pay attention to her
oh what she had to start the only fans
because he wasn't paying attention to
her are you guys kidding
me maybe he was busy
working maybe had other stuff going on
I'm sorry one year of not getting
attention is not worth only fans what
crazy people are you um anyways so I
wanted to point out why women like this
are delusional for a lifetime uh they
signal easy sex to other men and often
times they get a lot of takers even
though they're absolute degenerate so
let's pull up the
video what else have you been doing
besides only fans and what have y'all
been going through financially that you
felt you had to do this I've had a
bartending service called [__] chill
arrow with kiss since I've been here I
have um a moving company called major
movers and cleaning and then I also have
a massage business called the body rub
babes nice are the do the body rub babes
travel
yes they do are you one of the body rub
babes well I have been but now I kind of
like but if I wanted you to be one of my
body rub babes like uh would you be a
body rub babe for
me oh yeah sure okay cool cause I I
don't mean to be a professional or
anything like that but I can't stop
looking at your cleavage it's it's you
got your cleavage is popping babe you
can leave it how it was man you can
leave it exactly how it was man I right
now I'm thinking about
cleavage yeah so this guy shoots his
shot at this woman mid interview and
this is how these women go through life
and delusion obviously that's that's a
sexual ask that man is not going to wife
this o chick and porn star and so the
women go through life thinking they have
a higher sexual market value than they
do when really 's just an average chick
with big boobs she's I mean even worse
than that she's really a a prostitute
with some big
boobs and really she's never going to be
taken seriously she got lucky that she
got an NBA player to take her seriously
the first time um and but women keep
getting bailed out of their bad
decisions so let's see the rest of the
video cleavage and the body rub bab
but I don't cover schol not it's it's
like you know
yeah
baby um sorry to get off track man but
um sorry about that kiss we'll talk
afterwards but um about the body RAB and
everything else but um he just threw me
off for a minute if it's not me it' be
someone equally as beautiful I promise I
mean yeah I see why Joe is a little
upset you are very very pretty and from
at least the stomach up you're sexy and
gorgeous to say to say the
least and look she's she's a beautiful
woman she's a pretty woman but the issue
is she's really depleted her sexual
market value um she's just going to be
for fun now really she had a good thing
where she had it she's going to think
that the grass is greener on the other
side and for most women it is not most
single mothers do not remarry the
majority do not remarry I I want to
stress this to you guys the majority of
single mothers do not have Happy Endings
only 22% % get a guy to live with them
only around 15% get a guy to marry them
most do not remarry and selling dreams
sells them a happy ending that they will
not have so let's take a look at the
comments if your wife putting herself
out there
like um so let's look at the comments if
your wife is putting herself out there
like that it's fair game go to the next
one the fact that she says sure to being
his body rub girl and she didn't cover
up after his comments says that she is
for the streets
obviously um Batman says he's actually
helping the husband out showing that she
ain't [__] yeah and you know this is
women's nature they just tend to move on
to the next best thing they crave for
the excitement and once a woman has had
a certain lifestyle and a certain level
of excitement it is tough to go come
back from that so I started a new series
on Twitter called # IEM and I just
wanted to point out a phenomenon that I
noticed notic in the conservative
movement I noticed a lot of quote
unquote conservative women that were
married that would dress super
provocatively on the internet and it was
just a really interesting phenomenon
because they would be screaming that
they're conservative women and I think
ladies it's time to have a conversation
over a certain age it is inappropriate
to dressed like a young woman anymore
and not only is it inappropriate it's
actually sad
it it
looks it looks very pathetic when you
have an older woman trying to pretend
that she is young over a certain age
you're supposed to move differently
you're supposed to have a a sense of
maturity and Grace but now we have older
women cosplaying and dressing like they
are young women you are not young
anymore over the age of roughly 25 it's
time to cover up it's time to dress more
modestly now obviously modesty is good
amongst all ages but under the age of 25
people just tend to get get a pass you
know even with the guys you know they'll
they'll have their sneaker collection or
whatever um they'll they'll dress a
little more immature right but then when
you get to a certain age you are
supposed to dress with a little bit more
class and Grace for men and for women
but overwhelmingly I've seen
conservative women dressing like hookers
and it's even sadder when they're older
or married it's not even about how you
look so I wanted to show you guys a
couple examples of this I included both
good examples and bad examples on
Twitter and I wanted to have a
conversation and I want you guys to let
me know in the comments is this
appropriate for a wife and a mother this
outfit I would say no I would say over a
certain age it is time to put the boobs
away you know she looks good she is
absolutely a good looking woman but
she's in her 30s again like where is the
class and elegance that we used to have
over a certain age so the next
one um she's in her 50s oh wow that's
impressive I didn't even know that and
looks younger and hot at the same time
time to put your jealousy away so guys
nothing to do with jealousy these women
are good-looking the women I'm going to
bring up I I I brought up attractive
women and unattractive women and
moderate women the issue is not about
looks it's about pretending to be
something that you are not at this rate
why not dress up like a baby
because some of you want to dress like
you are 22 forever you are not 22
Forever at some point it is time it is
time to mature and grow up go to the
next one in context of what she posted I
think it's fine regardless if she's a
wife or a mom I think it's appropriate
and she looks great now I think over a
certain age it's time to put the boobs
away now a lot of people will say oh but
it's not my fault I have just these big
boobs that just spill out come on guys
really is it that hard to find a shirt
with this
neckline isn't that all they have to
offer though I mean think about it these
women have been around the block a few
times go to the next
one all right so then we have this
one yeah guys I'm gonna deem
this not terrible but the shorts look
pretty short well the picture is not too
bad but I I just think at a certain
point it's time to put the shirt up this
is barely inappropriate I rate this
barely barely inappropriate she's almost
there go to the next
one oh no that's inappropriate okay
that's sad but look at this okay she's
an inshape she's not a badl looking
woman but this woman has got a belly
button ring booty shorts a crop top and
flipflops you know and even the guy
let's look at the guy's appearance he he
looks like he's D like they both look
like they're older people dressed like
they're 16 and it's just this phenomenon
we have going in society where we have
older people that are trying trying to
pretend they're 16 and at some point
it's time to grow up and have a more
mature look and lifestyle like this
literally looks like an outfit that you
would see a a 16 15-year-old woman wear
I deemed these outfits inappropriate the
first one wasn't terrible but I I think
women go around not even knowing how
ridiculous you guys look you guys look
ridiculous it's sad and I'm not saying
you know I grew up as an athlete right
so I grew up in spandex every was really
short that's kind of what we were used
to so I never thought much about it but
as a society we can't even have the
conversation of what is appropriate and
what is inappropriate and at some point
guys it's time to cover up especially
when you have kids because why would you
want to teach your daughters to be
immodest and that is why I pushed this
so hard the wife and the mother that's
why I keep saying I deem this
inappropriate as a wife and a mother
because once you get married you have a
certain level of respect responsibility
to not model IM modesty because if you
have a son that's the type of wife
they're going to look for what you model
or if you have a daughter she is going
to look up to you and it is your job as
a mother to not be immodest um Pearl
this is what the mom wants to wear when
she feels good about herself why deny
her her feelings because again it's not
about you anymore and this isn't to say
that they're terrible mothers you know
everybody has a moment but it's not only
that they wear these outfits but they
post them for everybody to see why are
we so addicted to attention that there
can't be private family moments that are
just for the family why does everything
need to be public tradwife today says
posing and posting for sexual attention
while holding a baby is next level
inappropriate yes yes can you imag oh it
makes it worse these women will have
their kids and their [__] outfits and
they want me to somehow think it's
better that's worse Diane
worse okay really pearly thinks how so
my husband is in the picture with me on
the right we were in Vegas and it was
115 degrees outside people were walking
around in bathing suits that's how hot
it was okay well then maybe don't post
it and you know what's crazy women used
to wear long ass dresses in 100 degree
weather it's not that hard to put on
some light fabric guys or at least a
light cover up a sun dress I mean let's
why are we acting like naked is the only
option it's the only option really so
this woman Bamboozled me I was
Bamboozled by this woman at first I gave
her a green light I said yes what a
great outfit but I didn't notice she
wasn't wearing a bra I'm a girl so my my
I I go up she got me she pulled one over
on me so at first I deemed this
appropriate then the comments section
let me know very quick that it was
inappropriate visible nipple is highly
inappropriate I didn't even notice sorry
guys I didn't even
notice um you're losing it Pearl women
should wear a bra and cover their
nipples I'm sorry I'm
sorry definitely some Diamond Cutters
coming through the shirt okay guys yes I
get it I get it I missed that one
sometimes I get it wrong okay so this is
our good friend Rachel Wilson she's been
on the show appropriate outfit now and
this is another thing Rachel Wilson was
a stay-at-home wife of four children she
homeschooled her children and taught
them all the basic things right cooking
cleaning she still homeschools her kids
do you see Rachel with a bunch of Botox
the latest fashion trends no and it's a
Telltale sign when women are obsessed
with this stuff because guys it's a lot
of work it takes time to keep up on
what's trendy it takes time to go to the
doctor's office get your nails done put
a bunch of [__] in your face put on a
ton of makeup for an hour every day all
of that stuff takes time wives and
mothers are not focused on the latest
fashion trends they have a couple
Timeless pieces that they wear and their
focus is their family not themselves so
I said I deem this outfit appropriate
for a wife and a mother and I want you
guys also to continue this trend on
Twitter use the hash em and let me know
your local your favorite celebrities and
Trad influencers if their outfits are
appropriate the h us it must take to
consider yourself the Arbiter of what's
appropriate for other women to do with
their lives guys guys you could disagree
you know some people are saying the arms
are too much but I think in 2023 okay
I'm not saying we couldn't go even more
appropriate even more modest but you
know we got to do baby steps you know
what I mean I'm like I think Step One is
ladies it's time to put the boobs away
the bud away and the mid drift away I
think that's reasonable so when a
nutshell pearly things believes that if
you're a wife and mom you must dress
like Laurel I don't even know who that
is Engles who the hell is hard pass um
no I think it's about being modest you
crazy people like is it crazy to say hey
once I'm a wife and a mother it is time
to put away the sexual stuff is it is
that is it is that crazy once you become
a wife and a mother it's time to put on
one pieces it's time to wear more
sundresses is that can we at least agree
that's step one I'm not saying we can't
extend it to younger but guys I'm
already like fighting I'm ready fighting
for moms to put their boobs
away all right that's a nice photo the
matching tie is a nice touch go to the
next
one okay so this one I love this outfit
this was a tough one for me someone sent
it to me very cute outfit she's
absolutely beautiful and she's single so
she gets a little bit of a pass but too
short for a wife and a mother I would
deem it so now we have this woman um and
I want to point out to you guys what is
wrong with this picture so we have the
boobs out heavy makeup lip filler and
guys part of modesty is actually not
caking your face with makeup I know I
know this is crazy guys most men don't
even want that they don't want a pound
of makeup they want to know what you act
look like yeah the no shirt immodest
next how do you work out in that top I
mean my boobs would just pop out with
any type of movement in the gym yeah and
then then the women say oh why is he
staring at me oh I can't believe they're
staring [__] you're naked you're naked
what did you expect why don't we just
all walk around naked may as well at
this point yes yes yes yes I deem half
of her being synthetic inappropriate yes
it's immodest there's a part of modesty
so this one boobs are out there's a slit
the slit in itself is not the worst
thing in the world if maybe it was a
turtleneck but this yeah immodest heavy
makeup lots of surgeries again you're a
mother you represent your family why
must we have the boobs out and wait go
back actually and I'd like to say the
guy is kind of dressed like he's 16 too
put a shirt on
you know what I mean it's just over a
certain age it's time to dress with a
little more class and this is a prime
example of money does not buy class it
does not you are not classy just because
you have money I deem her inappropriate
as a wife and a mother in general also
what is it with these Kardashian chicks
shacking up with dudes with face tattoos
well it's because again they have money
but they have no class so they do not
qualify for the men that are classy
she's still advertising for the next
next
man and I deem that whole look
inappropriate as a man yeah I agree I
agree here we have Michaela Peterson now
this was a close one okay I wasn't
completely but the boobs are out heavy
makeup very short dress and knee high
stockings again this is a great I don't
want to say great but maybe a more
acceptable outfit if you're 22 but again
at some point
it's I'm just asking the wives and the
mothers it's time when you're married to
put the boobs away to maybe get can we
at least cover the top half of our legs
the top half okay I think especially as
conservative women over the age of 25
especially when you're married and have
children it is time to be more modest
now again everybody has their moments
this is no attack on anybody personally
but attacking the culture that we have
that encourages immodesty from
mothers I dress my wife in sexy outfits
to go out dancing because I like seeing
it and she's beautiful even after 13
years of marriage and three kids she
won't dress like that without me present
and won't post it on social media yeah
it's one thing to dress for your husband
but my question is why do sexual outfits
need to be public why can't they just be
private for you and your husband and at
what age how long does it take these
women to learn what's appropriate and
what's inappropriate why do we have
women at 30 30 35 45 still not knowing
what is appropriate as a wife and a
mother it is time to put the boobs Away
Ladies um I might have to disagree with
you here Pearl their stockings are way
up past their knees are you trying to
tell me they are too short that's why I
said this one was a close one I think
the stockings are kind of it's kind of a
sexual innuendo it's just a look okay
the biggest Flex a woman could have is a
small social media following and yeah so
let me know let me know if you think I
got any of these wrong right you know
I'm open to criticism let me know in the
comments but I think as a whole if
you're going to be preaching
conservative values online it is better
and especially once you are married it
is better to be more modest as a role
model for your children and in respect
to your husband so many times women get
married and act exactly the same as if
they were single I'm sorry but marriage
is supposed to come with sacrifice and
if you don't believe that it is supposed
to come with sacrifice if you don't
believe that it's For Better or For
Worse and richer and for poorer and you
are supposed to honor your husband that
I say stay out of marriage just be in a
long-term relationship people are doing
that but it's disrespectful to the
people that actually believe in marriage
so a couple of months ago I covered
alpacino
having a kid with a 28-year-old woman so
that's alpacino
that is his girlfriend they break up and
now he's being ordered to pay $330,000 a
month in child support this man is in
his 70s and
now it has to pay astronomical fees for
a child what on Earth do you need 30k a
month for for one kid is this money
really just going to be spent on the
children I think that any child I think
child support should be banned but if we
are going to keep having child support
it should be put in a fund that is only
used used for the kid that only the kid
gets it not the mother the comments on
this say 82 with a baby she ain't got
many
payments um to grow up and find out you
were just a pawn in your mama's getrich
scheme I still don't know what kid needs
$30,000 a month to live I'm 25 taking
care of myself and I pay real bills and
they damn sure don't cost that yeah what
why do kids have to have the same level
of Lifestyle
with their dad and with their mom
there's some idea that if the Mom leaves
she's somehow entitled to bring her
child up in a environment that is the
same luxury as the dad I say don't leave
your baby father if you can't pay for it
women should not be rewarded for leaving
and breaking up homes now this child is
growing up in a situation where you know
how old is alpacino going to live He's
82 and now he's being raised with a
mother that is a very clear Gold Digger
and you know this is all chaos and
speaking of chaos chances are you've
been here before the chaos in these
markets oil and stocks just when you
thought it was safe and interest rates
were Rising a new threat comes out of
nowhere tensions are boiling from Asia
to Europe adaptation is the key here to
safeguarding your wealth you may not
have considered Noble gold before it's
not speculation but insurance and right
now you need insurance Noble gold
Investments has been protect protecting
investors from disaster for years with
precious metals so if you're worried it
might be time to take a fresh look at
gold and silver gold is a proven safe
shield for your portfolio and a
volatility balance against uncertainty
if it helps Noble gold Investments is
offering a free 5 oce America the
Beautiful coin with its new IAS this
month if you open your Noble gold
Investments Ira or a 401k rollover you
can claim your coin today remember
crisis bruise portfolios waiver gold
insulates secure yourself against
threats go to noblegold investments.com
now that's noblegold investments.com the
only gold company that I trust so men
are outraged by this video there is a
video of a woman that got breast
reduction surgery going viral let's pull
it
[Music]
up gots in my head and they won't go
Spirits in my head and they won't go I
got guns in my head and they won't go
got guns in my head and they Spirits in
my head and they won't go I got in my
and Spirits in my head and they won't go
I got in my
and Spirits in my head and they won't
go so men have seen this video and are
outraged let's let's read the
comments do women consider ever just
wearing a bra now I've seen this go
viral because the men you know guys
because men really don't like it when
you get a lot of work done it's just not
their thing
um I've heard men compare this to you
know reduction surgery like to a GU I
don't want to say it but you guys get
that his shadow says I try to get my
girl to take off her bra
and hers are pretty big sadly she loves
the bra so much just looking at this
point she has two indents in her
shoulders just looking at the indents
from the bra strap it looks painful so
Ron says she went from being
overwhelmingly popular to average yeah
guys
men you know there's a lot of debate
because you know I guess women have back
issues when they have like big boobs but
you know the men are really outraged
about this okay guys so that concludes
our story St today I'm going to read the
top comment from last week let's pull it
up it feels weird to be mentally healthy
and you can clearly see who's ill and
who is not shout out to Roy Romeo 5329
for his comment guys if you want your
comment to be read put it in the comment
section below and the top liked comment
I will read tomorrow thank you guys for
watching like the video on your way out
get yourself a women shouldn't vote
t-shirt to support the channel and I
will talk to you next time